there has been a new stepped up effort
or some momentum to push AI regulation
we've got this meeting that happened
last week where the CEOs of the major AI
companies were summoned to the White
House to talk it out with Kamala Harris
there's apparently legislation underway
that Chuck Schumer is laying the
groundwork for according to some
reporting from axios Sam Altman the CEO
of openai which is kind of viewed as the
industry leader at this this point in
terms of large language models or you
know chat Bots
has said he welcomes regulations our
mission is to figure out how to build
these Advanced AI systems and deploy
them into society for maximum benefit
and that requires partnership with
government and regulation that companies
can do a lot and we talked about this
yesterday to get that started but
long-term term we will need governments
our government governments around the
world to act and to put regulation in
place and standards in place that make
sure that we get as much of the good as
possible of these from these
Technologies and minimize the downsides
longer term as these systems become
really really powerful I do think we
will need some sort of international
Authority
um that is that is looking at the people
building the most powerful systems and
making sure that we are running
evaluations for safety he's trying to be
a good you know corporate Citizen and
saying that I'm not you know regulation
isn't crazy and I guess what we want to
support it as you as you probably know
often industry leaders are fine with
regulation that creates a barrier to
entry to competitors so it's not not
strange that industry leaders might be
welcoming in regulation but you know our
fundamental question here has to be uh
is this the time to do regulation and if
we were going to do some sort of
Regulation what sort would be a good
idea uh as you know some kinds of
Regulation can just be heavy-handed and
really shut down Innovation and so I
would say if we're going to do anything
in the direction of Regulation let's
talk about what would be robust gentle
even Market based sorts of Regulation
that might address some of the concerns
but not hinder the rest of the industry
the CEO of Google who recently had this
to say on 60 Minutes one of the things
we need to be careful when it comes to
AI is avoid what I would call Race
conditions where
people working on it across companies
Etc so get caught up in who's first
that we lose you know the potential
pitfalls and downsides to it
and then we've also got a former
Google employee one of the
pioneers of the kind of AI research that
has led to the the emergence of these
models Jeffrey Hinton who
resigned from Google he says so that he
could speak a little more freely about
the risks that he sees I'm not an expert
on hydrogen regulation I'm just a
scientist who suddenly realized that
these things are getting smarter than us
um and I want to sort of blow the
whistle and say we should worry
seriously about how we stop these things
getting control over us
um and it's going to be very hard and I
don't have the solutions I wish I did
to any of these recent statements sway
you or in the pause Direction
I see these statements as mainly
speaking to the risk of AI in the next
few decades and that we should be
addressing that and dealing with it and
I agree with that I let's see them
saying that the next GPT 5 run could
kill us all that's the thing I was
disagreeing with if say you make a GPT 5
it's not an agent by itself but I agree
that you can make an agent out of it and
as you say you could make billions of
different agents out of it but if
millions of different people make
millions of different agents out of GTP
5 then they may well get better and
smarter but they are in a world of lots
of other humans and systems and other
AIS so the scenario of concern seems to
be that one of these AIS somehow takes
over the world
so it has to not just out compete its
owners and Builders who are watching and
testing it it has to out compete the
entire rest of the world in terms of
military and police and monitoring and
it has to out compete all the other AIS
made out of GT5 all the other agents if
if you release gpt5 and many people can
make agents out of it and they do they
will each one of them will be trying to
control their thing it might get out of
control but one person letting their
agent get out of control of them doesn't
destroy the world I think there's a lot
of reasons to think about you know
powerful AIS and what they can do and
how to manage a world with them I'm just
being skeptical about the scenario that
the next time we run gtv5 by itself
which isn't even an age and it's going
to destroy the world I think AES in
general in the last few years have been
knocking down various kind of benchmarks
faster than can then we can come up with
them so it's kind of
I would say it's almost strange to be
confident like confident as in like less
than one percent the GPT 5 would not be
significant to superhuman I mean gp4 is
already sort of like like 90th
percentile college student in in many
domains
okay so I'm granting that GPT 5 could be
super human on many performance
characteristics what I'm doubting is
that that destroys the world but as we
have to construct a scenario after you
have very smart gpt5 such that the world
gets destroyed and that's the path where
I'm I'm skeptical I I see you would use
it many people would use it many people
would then have access to a somewhat
superhuman uh capability many people
would use it for contrary purposes uh
police would use it military would use
it all the people defending us against
theft and destruction would also be
using it we would all be increasing our
capabilities with superhuman AI but that
doesn't directly destroy the world
is there a point Robin where you would
suddenly become concerned and want to
start signing on to the open letter like
what what are you looking for that is
going to raise the alarm for you
foreign
well certainly if people were trying to
make the worst case systems and like the
management and funding of a particular
you know most advanced projects were
trying to make the worst case scenarios
they went out of their way to make those
scenarios well then I get a lot more
worried about the starts I think they're
a priori less likely and I want to
discourage them through some sort of
liability so if people would only
accidentally produce the worst case
scenarios let's push them away from that
but obviously if you show me somebody's
going out of their way to make it then
I'm going to say hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our live stream with Robin Hansen and
Jan talin about artificial intelligence
existential risk and the dangers of
preemptive regulation you can watch our
full conversation right here or another
excerpt right here